nous sommes français
vos ancêtres les gaulois
un peu romain
[Musique]
un peu germain
un peu juif
un peu italien
espagnol de plus en plus portugais
peut-être qui sait polonais
et je me demande si déjà nous ne sommes
pas un peu arabe
comment voyez-vous la france nicolas
dupont aignan multiculturel comme
françois mitterrand ou d'abord gauloise
non
multiculturelle si c'est pour finir
comme le liban
ça sera la fin de la france sas et
communautaires multiplient culturel ci
s'est enrichie d'influencés diverses
mais rester français l'idée de la france
la france est pas une race c'est pas une
ethnie la france est une idée c'est la
liberté égalité fraternité
c'est ça la france et le problème
d'aujourd'hui c'est que un excès
de vagues migratoires avec une faiblesse
de l'état et une faiblesse de la
croissance et un abandon de la
souveraineté ça aboutit au liban et je
ne veux pas de ça et ça ne remet en rien
en cause les personnes c'est tout donc
il faut il faut une il faut une
diversité mais il ne faut pas une
négation de ce qu'on est c'est tout et
c'est l' équilibre entre les deux qui
est important donc mitterrand a
affaiblit considérablement le pays
parce que on peut accueillir du monde si
on a la force à 6 médiatrice et la force
de croissance mais on peut pas à la fois
abandonné la force de croissance la
force d'assimilation et à avoir les bras
ouverts on peut pas il faut choisir
gouverner c'est choisir j'étais plutôt
mendès-france peu mitterrand
[Musique]